hi I'm Erik Bosse and Venom was
definitely a more entertaining movie
that the critics are giving it credit
for I think the reason for this
disparity are a few details that some of
the more anal viewers are just getting
too hung up on one mystery that you
might have overlooked and venom involved
the time jump early in the movie
obviously spoiler warning if you haven't
seen venom yet as we meet the key
players Eddie Brock and and Carlton
Drake in San Francisco halfway across
the world the escaped riot symbiote hops
from body to body gradually making its
way over to them and then the film
suddenly jumps ahead six months to show
how Eddie's life has moved on after
getting fired and dumped but that time
Joe kind of leaves riot up in the air
what was riot doing for six months
director Ruben Fleischer admitted that
this is kind of a bump in logic in other
words apply at all but here's the thing
about potholes guys every movie has plot
holes and they're really only a problem
if they're so distracting that they take
you out of the moment and while watching
venema he honestly didn't think about
this specific timeline issue until
someone pointed out to me hours later on
the contrary my overactive imagination
sees a surprisingly fascinating
hypothetical journey for riot that is if
you love stuffing plot holes with
pointless research it's fun I had myself
quite a rare yeah you get it so I asked
you to detach yourself from skepticism
and join me on this thought experiment
where exactly yes right okay let's look
at the map movies opening scene an
on-screen title establishes the Space
Shuttle crash site as East Malaysia a
close look at the light foundation
computer screens shows the northern
coastline of the island of Borneo which
Malaysia shares with Indonesia in Brunei
Carlton Drake asks where the shuttle
went down and his assistant tells him 20
kilometers west of Cebu Naboo is
actually a town in East Malaysia 20
kilometers west of it places a crash
site at around these coordinates now an
EMT comes into contact with astronaut
John Jameson by the way that's the son
of Daily Bugle editor Jay jonah Jameson
one of the mini Marvel Easter eggs that
I go into my full breakdown of the movie
go watch it in this ambulance the riot
symbiote transfers from Jameson to the
EMT who's played by Michelle Lee causing
the ambulance to crash the EMT and right
from there take off on foot now
according to the map the closest major
road is here and I assume it was headed
to the nearest city of been to Lou I
think that's a general area of the
market that the EMT stumbles upon it
would have been about a five and a half
hour walk
so here the riot symbiote attacks a
bunch of townspeople and it hops over to
a new host
that of a middle-aged woman played by
Vicki in this is the last we see of riot
and this woman until six months later in
the Hong Kong Airport now what was this
woman doing for six months judging from
drakes other test subjects these
symbiotes can't last that long and a
human host body they start to eat the
human's organs only by achieving
symbiosis and eating other living
creatures can they survive the way venom
did with Eddie Brock so I think we can
assume that riot bonded with Vicki in in
the same way something about this older
Malaysian woman must have just checked
the box for this alien military commando
maybe she had a fighting spirit he was
she takes no prisoners at mahjong the
director actually offered this
explanation I like to think that old
lady was going around murdering all
throughout Malaysia and she was just
having a good time shooting shards
through different people I mean who's to
know
that's a bit more than mahjong though
six months is a long time for a killing
spree around Malaysia but I guess the
riots gotta eat right the venom comics
explain that the reason the symbiotes
eat human heads is that they need the
chemical phenyl tile amine which is
found in the human brain it's also found
in chocolate but you know going after a
brain just kind of gives you a chase now
I'm not sure how frequent of a phenyl
tile I mean fix these symbiotes need but
let's assume it's one brain per day
we're trying to fill up six months of
time here so that would be about 180
bodies you think if an older woman was
doing that around Malaysia someone
wouldn't notice
besides based on the way that that EMT
looked at the light foundation patch
riot was on a mission it didn't want to
sit around dormant in this older
Malaysian woman and goof around for a
while it needed to get to San Francisco
ASAP right it is traveling for work not
pleasure so what if it just took a
really long time for riot to get there
is it possible to travel that
inefficiently after spending way too
long looking at Southeast Asian travel
routes yes kind of let's go back to look
at wind riot fused with Vicky Haines
perhaps in the city of been - from there
the fastest way to get to Hong Kong
would be a direct flight but a fleet
wouldn't be that simple you need a
passport for one and while direct
flights are relatively cheap from US
standards the median annual income of
been too low is just a little over ten
thousand US dollars per year and this
woman appeared to be a street vendor in
an area where knife-wielding gangs are
patrolling so I just doubt that she
travels a lot or has much disposable
income I guess you can argue that maybe
part of the six months could have been
riot robbing Malaysian convenience
stores or just working on honest a job
selling eels gradually building the
funds to afford
plane ticket and then of course take a
passport photo without the eyes milking
over or maybe part of the six months
could have been riot having some trouble
with air travel Malaysian Airlines
doesn't exactly have the best track
record no I'm not suggesting that right
caused the tragic flight disasters with
Malaysian Airlines flight 370 was
actually headed from Kuala Lumpur to
Beijing different flight route anyway
the second fastest way to get to Hong
Kong would be of course to swim remember
Borneo is an island
luckily apparently symbiotes can swim
like friggin torpedoes number venom
while escaping the light foundation in
San Francisco swam across the bay the
distance of four and a half miles
judging by the length of the Oakland Bay
Bridge
they swim crazy fast look how fast
exactly I've asking anything swim well
the fastest swimming animal on earth is
no not Michael Phelps shut up the
indo-pacific sailfish which can swim up
to 68 miles per hour
and since venom is a super strong
extraterrestrial let's just round up and
put his top swimming speed at 70 miles
per hour
if riot can swim that fast it could swim
from Ventoux Lou to Hong Kong a distance
of 1169 nautical miles about 17 hours if
it's women top speed the whole time
without braking but that might be too
long a distance
so suppose riot decided to swim west
from batu lu a distance of 563 nautical
miles to singapore and work its way up
to hong kong through the mainland that
swim would take about eight and a half
hours top speed without bricks but a
long swim doesn't seem that practical
for riot does it it would take so much
energy bryant would have to stop and
hunt for food it could get lost got a
train for that kind of thing so let's
assume right just took a boat to
Singapore most cargo ships travel around
24 knots which is about 28 miles per
hour
that's me it would take about a day to
get there from Singapore riot could set
out on foot and walk the long walk to
Hong Kong about 2,500 miles now walking
an average speed of 3 miles per hour it
would take around 35 days so I think it
is fair to assume it could have taken
riot at least three months from figuring
out boat schedules have been to Lu and
sneaking aboard cargo ship and then
wandering a planet that this thing is
unfamiliar with through difficult
terrain across five countries on foot of
course taking breaks to rest and feed
and clean up at mahjong
to eventually arrive at the Hong Kong
Airport but of course that still leaves
three months but we do not know how long
riot was at that Airport remember the
movie the terminal
Thanks lived in JFK for nine months and
that movie was inspired by the real-life
story of an Iranian refugee who lived in
Charles de Gaulle Airport for 18 years
I'm just saying three months is a
totally reasonable amount of time for
Vikki egg riot to live in the Hong Kong
Airport returning luggage carts for
quarters and then using that to buy
whoppers and of course occasionally
eating people people do go missing in
China all the time sadly so there you go
six months of riot and the body of Ikki
Aang zigzagging through Southeast Asia
and sneakily 80 people in the Hong Kong
Airport now sure you could say it'd be
way more practical for riot to hop into
a different body of someone more rich
you could travel someplace more directly
but again this is one special lady folks
she must have been a serious badass for
riot to stick with her for six months
and we need to see her story
forget carnage or a Spider Man crossover
then sequel needs to be Viki Aang and
Wyatt deadliest mahjong players and Hong
Kong international terminal 1 now look
you may just say this is all a plot hole
and I'm wasting my time but you know
what else is a plot hole the absurdity
of a society capable of space travel not
having a better way to transfer stolen
battle plans and then a droid in a
princess in that plot hole inspired a
whole movie look whatever your thoughts
were on rogue one a Star Wars story
that's fine don't scramble to hand off
those battle plants like a rugby ball
was undeniably fun these happy accidents
of what we should live for and if you
think I sound crazy here you should see
what I do with the logic pumps of the
Pixar Cars universe ooh baby parts 911
that's that's all I'm gonna say comment
down below with your theories and follow
me on twitter and instagram at a boss
for more rantings and ravings about
things no one should think that hard
about subscribe to new rockstar some
more or entertaining over analysis of
the stuff that you love and nerdy
defenses of plot holes flat holes aren't
that bad oh god I got a plot holes
forming underneath my feet I'm falling
remember me